could knuckle defeat maram knuckle is of
course one of the very few characters in
Hunter Hunter with a nen ability that
could technically bring down the ant
king I'm not saying that it's at all
likely but I want to know if it's
possible and this matchup is sponsored
by Squarespace the platform that
provides you with the tools to create
your own custom websites and online
stores to engage with your audience on
your terms but more about them later and
knuckle is a very fun candidate to
analyze because his inability despite it
being quite complex is actually very
straightforward and completely
unambiguous because it's all matths as
opposed to other potential maram Killers
like say thinkx whose rip a cyclotron
could maybe technically if given enough
time produce enough power to kill
marowan but the problem is we have no
way of measuring that power and
therefore no way of knowing how many
times it is that FX would need to rotate
his armed charge it and therefore how
long it would take to do all of the
rotations with knuckle however we can
calculate his ability to defeat marow
right down to the second so we're going
to ask what is Knuckles an N ability
hakar how much Aura does maram have and
how long would it take for knuckle to
bankrupt the ant king let's begin
knuckle is a very simple boy and Hunter
Hunter he's a natural emitter with one
hatu called hakari which has one known
function being bankruptcy Chapter 7 here
knuckle owns a portion of his Aura
usually delivered via rolence and punch
consisting of anywhere between 2 to 300
units of Aura Aura which the opponent is
in free to use however they'd like yes
this hatu actually makes the opponent
stronger however there is a however at
some stage during fight the opponent
must pay back the aura loaned which by
itself isn't too difficult of a task
however every 10 seconds the loaned Aura
acrs interest at a rate of 10% rapidly
making the aura payment amount bigger
and bigger all of which is kept track of
by this delightsome little mascot called
APR which stands for amortizing power
redirector knuckle has effectively
weaponized the concept of compound
interest but the intention is that the
number grows out of control so quickly
that the opponent becomes physically
incapable of repaying it thus defaulting
on their debt and going bankrupt and
once bankrupt APR transforms into IRS
the individual Ren suppressor and forces
the user into a state of zetsu for 30
days making them completely nude no Aura
control no abilities able to be used and
just leaving them very very vulnerable
and hakara has no maximum debt limit so
there is no creature on this planet or
whatever the hunter hunter world is no
creature on the that can outdo hakara in
a strict Battle of attrition and that
includes maram there are some caveat
though for interest to a crew knuckle
must be within 50 m of his opponent
which is confusing because hunt Hunter
itself is very inconsistent about this
in chapter 235 the radius was initially
stated to be 100 m but then in chapter
308 it appears to be Recons to 50 m on
the bright side neither knuckle nor the
opponent are able to physically hurt
each other whilst hakara is active all
of the punch fighting back and forth
just equates to loaring more Aura and
repaying Aura however the ability will
cease as soon as the loan repayment is
made in full to knuckle AKA if knuckle
was to punch you you with 200 units of
Aura and then you immediately smacked
him back with a 200 AA punch then you've
paid him back and hakara deactivates but
obviously that becomes much more
difficult if you're unable to hit
knuckle within even a minute of the
ability activating because again
interest URS every 10 seconds so now all
we need to figure out is how many units
of Aura maram has and we have our answer
that's much less simple though we need
to start with maro's royal guard UPI
it's very commonly stated on the
internet that up has an approximate Aura
quantity of 700,000 units and this is
because knuckle himself stated that Up's
Ora could be about 10 times out of moral
who had 70,000 units I want to stress
that this is far from an exact
measurement though in the manga knuckle
manages to just suck a punch up activate
hakara and then knuckle simply says I
can't see the limit of his Aura and then
the narat went on to describe knuckle as
a veteran over 5,000 battles no was able
to quantify his opponent's power based
on past experiences and Instinct and
coming across a foe with unprecedented
Powers was not even a rare event but up
was a monster with such a Titanic amount
of aura that he was on an entirely
different scale than even the most
powerful opponents knuckle had ever
fought so here's a common misconception
kno's hatu doesn't give him the ability
to strictly quantify Aura that's just an
extra sense that he sort of developed as
a result of using this ability in over
5,000 battles which is that it's a lot
of battles by the way knuckle isn't all
that old maybe mid to late 20s and to
have already fought 5,000 battles is
something like a fight every 2 days
since he was born but the aura
quantification is something that knle
has developed as a vague Instinct it's
not a precise number and because knuckle
had never faced an opponent on Up's
level before knuckle was left completely
in the dark like trying to measure the
length of a city when all you have is
one of those wooden 30 cm rulers from
primary school so knuckle is forced to
make a guess he initially posits that up
Zora is five times more than moral but
then corrects himself to 10 times but
but also ominously adds more he has no
idea however for the sake of coming up
with a practical plan knle decides to
use the 10 times number and calculate
how long it would take for up to go
bankrupt and I'd say it wasn't all that
bad a guess considering that later on
during the palace Invasion the narrator
blatantly states that up has less than
500,000 AA units remaining the problem
being we don't know how much AA up spent
before that point given his tremendously
overwhelming abilities it was likely
quite a bit and he would continue to
spend big because the final number we
see on APR for up is
37,6 184 which was displayed less than 5
seconds before up was set to go bankrupt
so according to that really helpful
clock that pops up all over the palace
Invasion according to that up spent
about 100,000 Aura in the space of about
3 and 1/2 minutes so if up was forced to
go through the energy rating system then
he would get zero probably even minus
stars but with that in mind I think that
700,000 units Vora might even be
conservative for up he could even be
approaching the million mark but fair
play to knuckle because he was in the
right General range of unattainability
but then we have marow and look knuckle
can feasibly hit marm the same way he
did with up via collaborating with
meeron and his perfect plan hatsu which
makes them both nice and seemingly
non-existent but in the same way that up
was completely off the scale for the
most above average of human n users
maram is completely off the scale for
the Royal Guards the only way that maram
could possibly make his presence more
dominant would be with the sponsor of
this video Squarespace through squ space
you can sell anything through an
exceptionally easy to set up online
store be it physical digital or service
products in my case I sell physical
shirts and mate you would be surprised
just how much of a pain doing something
as simple as that can be which is why I
genuinely use and love Squarespace
because they make it merely simple yet
somehow still really good Squarespace
offers an incredible amount of ready too
website templates that are customizable
to your heart's content through the
fluid engine a Next Generation website
design system to further unlock and
cultivate your creativity so you can can
and should check out Squarespace through
my link in the description which will
save you 10% off your first purchase of
a website or domain and thank you so
much again to Squarespace because it's
sponsors like this that make producing
our fictional Hunter content possible on
a regular basis so please do check them
out but for now it's back to you me so
if we go with knuckles's original scale
which again turned out to be somewhat
Accura is you might be able to assume
that maram aura is conservatively 10
times out of up so if we wanted to use
the popular knuckle calculation then
we're looking at at least seven million
units of Aura honestly it could be a lot
more but I'm going to use this
conservative number to demonstrate just
how absurd the situation is so let's say
that knuckle lands a really hard punch
we're talking like 300 units of aura
that kind of punch with that and that
alone at that rate it would take almost
17 minutes for marow to go bankrupt but
look knuckle he's a very resourceful boy
for example in the fight against gone he
actually loaned gon some more Aura what
what a generous guy which took gon's
debt to just over 500 Ora so let's use
that let's say he's able to land two
punches on maram these punches totaling
500 Ora if that was to be the case then
that would cut Knuckles overall Time by
not even a single minute with 500 units
of Aura compounding by 10% interest
every 10 seconds maram would go bankrupt
at 16 minutes on the dot which I bring
up because look you can definitely see
knuckle being able to hit marowan once
so long as he and Mell are on a using
God's accomplice that is but it's very
very difficult to see knuckle being able
to hit maram a second time and what's
worse is that the reward for hitting him
a second time is almost meaningless in
the grand scheme of things because
remember that knuckle needs to stay
within 50 MERS of maram for 16 whole
minutes and also remember that in the
final Clash of netro versus maram they
exchanged over a th000 blows in less
than a minute it was a rough ask for
even Isaac Neto to survive 16 minutes
with marijam in fact their whole fight
was probably less than that so you know
what we we need to be super generous
here if no's going to have any chance
that's just what we going to have to do
let's say that knuckle has a plan like a
really good plan and he gets in a flurry
of hits they're not going to be as
powerful as one concentrated hit but
each punch has say 250 units of or
backing it and maybe knuckle is good
enough to hit maram 10 times so that's
an initial investment of 2,500 units
that marijam needs to repay and in this
absolutely outrageously lucky case to
start with such a huge Advantage it
would still take just over 13 minutes to
bankrupt marijam that's the thing about
com pound interest with the principal
amount it can often feel like it's doing
nothing nothing at all for years and
years on end then it just hits a point
where it quite rapidly snowballs it's
all about patience and that's not
something we can really afford with
marijam because at this point even doing
the impossible has only managed to shave
three minutes of an almost 17-minute
battle against a God so it's looking
pretty bad but we do still have one
option let's take knuckle's absolute
best case scenario because the ant king
marowan he's always down for a game so
if knuckle strolls in and says yep yo
ant bro let me hit you with 100% of my
aura it'll be fun marowan would likely
respond with sure thing mate so is
knuckle's maximum amount of Aura enough
to bring down marow as quickly as we
need to be well weirdly knuckle has
never revealed how much Aura he has he's
very good at exposing everyone else whil
keeping his own Secrets but in theory he
doesn't need all that much hakara is a
very low AA hatu and other than that all
knuckle really uses AA for is basic
enhancement as well as the basic and
advanced principles of nen knuckle's Max
output probably isn't all that much
higher than gonz which is 21,500 when it
comes to the hand-to-hand enhancer style
fighting that were pretty evenly matched
which is great for knuckle he he's not
an enhancer he's a natural emitter so to
think he could take on a natural
enhancer in pure hand-to-hand n combat
speaks to both his experience and his
quantities of Aura gone himself even
knew that he would be at a disadvantage
if he fought knuckle in a battle of
attrition and that's why gone was always
dipping into his D junkan series he
couldn't beat knuckle straight up so his
only option was to try andate create an
opening for one big old punch whatever
the case knuckle was a clear Step Above
gone in terms of Aura quantity I'd put
him anywhere between 30 to 40,000 units
just due to how comfortable he was
keeping Pace with gone and keeping in
mind that there's definitely a big gap
between knuckle and moral as well for
the sake of argument let's be generous
we're going to go on the upper end let's
say that knuckle has a maximum Aura
output of 40,000 units and that marow
agrees to let knuckle hit him with all
40,000 units surely surely surely with
that much debt marowan would have but
seconds to pay it off before going
bankrupt and losing n himself well again
prepared to be very disappointed by
maths because with a very generously
estimated maximum potential of Knuckles
full power maram would go bankrupt in
about 8 and 1 half minutes and against
marow that may as well be 16 minutes it
may as well be an hour it may as well be
a day the only way for this to work
would be to somehow invest an amount of
aura that would send marowan bankrupt
faster then melon's perfect plan
deactivates aka before melon needs to
breathe which actually the dude can hold
his breath for a pretty long time a
maximum of 2 minutes so with that in
mind how much Aura would we need to make
maram go bankrupt in 2 minutes well in
order to accomplish this with perfect
plan you would need to hit maram with an
initial investment of just over 3
million units of Aura which is the
equivalent of 139 full power guns
striking maram with 100% of everything
they have simultaneously now let's say
we find a way for that impossible
situation to occur maram is bankrupt
within 2 minutes knu comes out he says
haha you fell for my for the thing I did
even after all of that does it even
matter one of the most terrifying things
about maram is that despite being the
most powerful living thing in a world
full of nen users he himself barely uses
nen at all in fact almost every
application we saw of nen from maram had
nothing to do with offensive abilities
we saw him use go which he could do from
birth we also saw him use n to a degree
that I don't think any living thing will
ever match and he did also use Ren but
that's more of a psychological attack a
violent projection of Ora like a big old
nen peacock and with Ora synthesis he
does have the ability to Devour the aura
and even n ability of others which only
enhanced his reserves further and did
show us an extremely rare case of maram
using Aura offensively when he fired one
of Up's rage blasts into a mountain
range and wiped it out with a single
casual hit I know this seems absurd but
I say all of this just to point out that
maram doesn't even really use the power
system that he was born into as an
effective God even against netro you
could make the argument that maram never
went beyond the very basic principles he
really only used 10 and Ren so what I'm
getting at is that even if knuckle
manages to reduce maram to a state of
zetsu even then I think that maram is so
naturally strong and fast that knuckle
still wouldn't be able to beat him and
that's after we've stacked Miracle on
Miracle to get knuckle to this point so
could knuckle beat maram maybe but he
would need to hit the ant king with an
aura investment totaling almost four
whole royal gods and that's at the
conservative end so we'll change that
maybe to a no he just isn't capable of
generating the principal amount
necessary but you let me know in the
comments who do you think has a better
chance of beating maram than knuckle